no one can deny that one movie we've
been waiting for a sequel on
none
[Music]
two is exactly what you think it is it's
a sequel to the nun in The Conjuring
Universe it's directed by Michael Chavez
who's been the director of other
Conjuring Universe movies I haven't
given a [__] about so I'm just going
into the nun too being like all right
here we go again I'm not gonna lie to
you for the first half of this movie I
was bored out of my skull probably would
have helped this being a sequel to the
nun if I had remembered anything about
the first nun movie but when I say I'm
just not gonna remember this one in
T-minus one day I mean it I didn't
remember anything the movie does do a
good job at filling you in it's almost
like they understand that I appreciate
that they understand people are going to
fall into two camps people who haven't
seen the first nun movie and people who
don't remember the first nun movie yeah
for the first half of this movie in
terms of the horror it's all horror
movie techniques that you've seen a
billion times before is it even possible
for us to see something a billion times
over in this short blip known as Life by
God when it comes to movies sometimes it
feels that way my thought was taze JFR
Mega is too good for this in fact I
don't mind saying she carries most of
the film she was really good compelling
has that sense of vulnerability but the
things that are happening are happening
at this boarding school and she's not
even there yet now you're hanging out at
this boarding school if you're not
inundated with horror movie techniques
you've seen a billion times before
you're dealing with that's right school
yard bullies because that's kind of
that's what we have to fill the daytime
with there were a couple of cool if not
unexpected deaths I do appreciate that
there was a cool standout magazine stand
moment of imagery but they showed that
in the trailer would have been far
cooler if I didn't know it was coming
when I saw the magazine stand I was like
here we go that scene that was cool in
the trailer and cool now doesn't change
the fact that for the first half I do
reiterate the first half of this movie I
had that light bulb moment I was like
this is why people are douchebags in
movie theaters why they got to get on
their phones with their bright ass
screen glaring ruining the experience
for everybody I usually get pissy when I
see that because it's a movie is like
hey I want to be engaged I want to at
least try but in this movie I understood
I was like
God I wish I was a douchebag right now
go for some eBay sniping in the movie
theater right this moment for the life
of me I finally understood you still
shouldn't do that that's a dick move but
I'm just saying boredom can drive you to
really dark thoughts like going on your
phone in a movie theater but I gotta say
the second half of this movie far better
than the first half it's never scary in
terms of a horror movie If you're
looking for that horror movie that's
going to scare the living [__] out of
you this is not it nothing in this movie
scared me but in adult life you come to
grips with the fact that movies
generally speaking are less scary at
this point because the things that scare
you are not that things that scare you
are no longer ghosts in the shadows
anymore you wake up in a flop sweat like
oh God
I did pay that bill okay oh it's just a
nightmare adulting is far less
interesting my friends but it's just the
way it is but if it's not going to be
scary at least be entertaining and I
felt the second half of this movie had
some really entertaining visuals even a
little bit of Raiders of the Lost Art
going on you'll kind of not exactly but
you know what the Crystal and the the
light kind of it's almost like there was
a realization like okay we're not really
that scary in fact we're breaking no new
ground when it comes to horror movies so
we're just gonna be entertaining and
look kind of cool
all right done that's when I started
enjoying myself with the tension if it's
not going to be scary at least be kind
of badass use that Catholic guilt lore
as a weapon hell yeah here we go we're
taking on evil even at a couple of
emotional moments again sold by Tasia
farmiga's performance that's why I say
she carries the film in the end I'll say
and with a caveat this movie probably be
a fun enough time if you're drunk yeah
now it's a party perfect with drinks for
the upcoming Halloween party this
October the caveat being just fast
forward until about halfway through the
movie from then on probably have fun so
you've been waiting patiently with
baited breath and you finally get to
talk about the nun too have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
foreign